somewhere along this journey you may see
some personality quirks that are
weird
[Music]
every scene in the movie is trying to
accomplish something do all the things
that you
have in your mind that will inform the
audience when they see this character
for oh that's
who that is after taking this class
you will be able to walk into a room
present your best self
and be happy with the result
we are living in a world of make-believe
so make it up
when you're at home preparing you break
down what he's trying to convey
the person he's speaking to and to the
audience the truth is
it's who you are inflicted upon the
truth of the dialogue that's written
there and we all have comfort zones the
hard work sometimes as an actor
is getting out of your comfort zone
if you have a personal biography for
your character
that's a way to get inside of them
figure out you know why does he talk
this way
is he a loner does he have friends is he
a cynic
learn what acting techniques are in
other cultures
you might find it more interesting than
the way we normally do it
in an audition don't say to them i don't
think my character would do that
because your character won't do that
because
you won't be hired and you won't be
getting that check
[Music]
i made a decision early in my life that
i wasn't gonna
live and die in chattanooga tennessee
being able to
embody a lot of different characters in
film
has been very cathartic being able to
let go
of the anger or the disappointment that
i had in my life
essentially we're entertainers find a
way to make yourself special
give it something that will distract
people from their daily lives in a way
that allows them to
live in this moment with us for a while
and leave there and
be energized by it and love it
i'm sammy little jackson and this
is my master class
you